platz den wir letzten sitzung hatten ist
sicherlich der größte denker den es gibt
zusammen mit aristoteles und auch noch
kann denen wir ja auch noch behandelt
werden
wir hatten nicht alles über platten
diskutiert weil wir uns ja sehr mit
einem mutter teresa beispiel
auseinandergesetzt hatten das hat für
viel diskussionsstoff gesorgt was jetzt
gut eigentlich genannt werden kann ist
es die handlung die gut ist ist es die
motivation oder sollte es nicht die
einheit von motivation und handlung oder
nutzen sein
und da kann ich in diesem zusammenhang
schon mal einen weiteren wichtigen
begriff an die tafel schreiben der heute
auch auftreten wird in der diskussion
bei aristoteles aber ich möchte ihnen
einfach mal schon mal bekannt machen das
ist der begriff des höchsten ups das
höchste gut ist ein begriff den wir
schon bei aristoteles jetzt heute
kennenlernen werden in einer ganz
bestimmten bedeutung und in dieser
wendung in der deutschen wendung ist
dieser begriff von immanuel kant geprägt
worden
und das bedeutet letztendlich die
einheit oder proportionalität ich
erkläre es gleich genauer die
einheitlichkeit die
angemessenheit die gleichzeitigkeit von
moralität und glückseligkeit
haben sie eine idee was das bedeuten
könnte die proportionalität von
moralität und glückseligkeit was kann
damit gemeint sein
sollte er sein genau das ist also ein
postulat sand das ist also eine
forderung eine forderung unserer
vernunft und das würde von ihnen
sicherlich jeder zugestehen wenn wir
moralisch sind oder moralischer wir sind
desto glücklicher sollten wir auch sein
also moralität sollte sich lohnen
das ist so eine intuition die wir haben
dass das würde unsere unsere vernunft
uns sagen sagt sie auch noch
es wäre eigentlich gerecht es sollte so
sein dass wenn wir moralisch handeln
moralisch sind wir glücklich sein
sollten oder glücklich werden sollten
das ist denke ich intuitiv einsichtig
und dieses diese forderung tritt
deswegen auf weil es häufig fälle gibt
wo jemand moralisch handelt und habe
kein glück hat sie kennen alle den
spruch die ehrliche ist der dumme
kennen sie alle
oder sie kennen den fall wo jemand eine
person sehr moralisch gehandelt hat ein
ideal ist ein idealist hinsicht etwas
eingesetzt hat und am ende dank für die
gesellschaft nicht und sie erleidet
sogar noch irgendwelche schäden oder
wird getötet
das kennen sie alle solche beispiele und
dann fragt man sich das ist doch nicht
gerecht
und das ist dieser hintergrund bekannt
dass er sagt unsere vernunft postuliert
sie fordert aus sich heraus sie fordert
auch wenn es nicht immer der fall ist
aber sie fordert dass es notwendig sein
sollte das moralität und glückseligkeit
in einer einheit stehen dass derjenige
der moralisch handelt auch glückselig
sein sollte oder glückselig werden müsse
man kann jetzt noch mal zwei formen
unterscheiden glückselig sein und
glückselig werden
ja also es gibt eine these die sagt
moralisch handeln bedeutet schon
glücklich zu sein
wer moralisch handelt ist schon
glücklich warum weil seinen willen seine
willensbildung wir haben das eine
letzten sitzung die bildung seines
willens seine willensfreiheit
ihnen eine stimmung versetzt in einem
zustand versetzt der harmonie genannt
werden kann
wir richten uns nach dem gebot der
vernunft bekannt zum beispiel aus
wir richten uns nach den interessen der
allgemeinheit aus und dieses diese
orientierung an der allgemeinheit oder
an dem sittengesetz becker
die sorgt dafür dass wir innerlich in
eine harmonie eintreten oder tugendhaft
sind mit platin oder paris tot ist wir
haben die seelen harmonie und dann
können wir sagen moralität impliziert
schon glückseligkeit
es gibt aber viele beispiele wo eben
moralisches handeln dann zu großem leid
führt weil die gesellschaft das nicht
mag wenn man sich für gewisse ideale
einsetzt oder wenn man auf missstände
hinweist
wie kann es sein dass jemand vielleicht
erzählen harmonie hat in einem ersten
moment vielleicht glücklich ist aber
dann sehr viel leid erfährt das heißt
der zweite sind von glückseligkeit wäre
der die langzeitfolgen ja gehts denen
dann auch irgendwie gut und die einheit
von beiden momenten von moralität und
von glückseligkeit die fordert das
höchste gut das also ein postulat von
und wir werden darauf bei kant noch
näher kommen so wir waren noch mal bei
plattform stehen geblieben platon hatte
dieses sonnen gleichnis und das
höhlengleichnis ich habe da noch zwei
folien ich werde die folien auch noch
ins netz stellen die finden sie dann
auch noch mal
und wer von ihnen kann man mal kurz
sagen was die analogie in diesem song
gleichnis war
worin besteht das gleichnis im song
gleichnis was mit was auf eine gleiches
ebene gebracht
wissen sie das
genau die sonne auf der einen seite das
haben wir hier
und die idee des guten muss man auch
genau dazu sagen da die idee dass gruppe
was hat es denn nochmal mit dieser idee
des guten auf sich warum kann platons
sagen dass die idee des guten der sonne
sehr ähnlich ist es in welcher analogie
steht die idee des guten zu sondere
genauer genommen die sonne zu idee
diskutiert
genau ein mal ist es die zugangs weise
zur sonne
wir schauen die sonne eigentlich nur
sehr selten an ich habe gesagt das
verursacht schäden und dass davon ruhig
wörtlich nehmen diese analogie genauso
problematisch ist es die idee des guten
zu schauen oder zu erkennen das ist
eines also wir ist es nichts empirisches
gewissermaßen obwohl die sonne natürlich
ein natürlich vorkommendes objekt ist es
gibt noch eine weitere relation das ist
sehr wichtig vor hinten war noch eine
meldung
also sie haben den erkenntnis grund
genannt mehr oder weniger also sie haben
davon gesprochen wie wir die sonne
erkennen oder vielleicht auch was wir
dank der sonne erkennen die sonne
stiftet und spendet uns das licht die
sonne erzeugt ein raum des sichtbaren
ein sichtbares feld in dem überhaupt
erst sichtbares als solches auftritt und
erkannt werden kann
die bedingung der möglichkeit von
erkenntnis wenn ich hier die fenster
zumachen die rolle in runterlassen das
licht ausschalten dann sehen sie nichts
mehr
sie werden aber selbst noch da sie
existierten noch sie könnten aber
einander nicht sehen oder erkennen und
deswegen ist es richtig war es noch der
kommilitone dazu sagt die sonne ist
nicht nur der erkenntnis grund von
sinnlich wahrnehmbaren sondern auch der
science grund sie ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit der existenz des jeweilig
natürlich vorkommende die pflanzen
zumindest bei steinen wird es schon
schwierig brauchen steiner die sonne
aber was lebendig ist was wächst das
wächst nur deswegen weil die sonne
sonnenlicht spendet weil photosynthese
usw
dadurch erst möglich ist das heißt es
scheint mal hin
idee des guten die guten ist sowohl der
erkenntnis grund als auch der science
grund
der dinge
[Applaus]
und hier haben wir jetzt sehr schön
dieses höhengleichen was in der letzten
sitzung nicht mehr behandeln konnten
aber was sie bestimmt gelesen haben und
das sollen gleichnis parallel parallel
aufeinander bezogen ganz oben ist die
dass guten darunter stehen die ideen wie
die idee des baumes hier die idee des
baumes und die idee ist das eigentlich
sein weil sie konstant ist die bäume
variieren jeder einzelne baum entsteht
und vergeht die idee der begriff könnte
man auch sagen des baumes konstant die
folien mache ich ihn noch zugänglich das
ist übrigens aus dem dtv atlas
philosophie entnommen
dieses hier hilfreiche übersicht und das
ganze ordnung von seinem sack platt und
es gibt die idee des guten also das ist
die ontologie könnte man sagen ist die
ontologien dass die gleichen ebene
die unterlage ist die lehre vom sein was
existiert und wir haben gesehen was ist
denn das problem der idee des guten
nochmal mit blick auf die unter logi die
existenz was sagt nämlich plattform über
die idee des guten hinsichtlich ihres
seins status lehnen sie sich noch das
war eine sehr schwierige wendung die
sehr vieldeutig ist was sagte dan ist
die des guten 11
ja genau
sie ist jenseits des zaunes nicht es sei
denn sein des seins wie auch immer man
dieses jenseits jetzt verstehen hat es
ist eigentlich kein sein dass die idee
dass es ist dasjenige was überhaupt erst
sein ermöglicht könnte man sagen ja im
sinne wieder der erkenntnis und das
existieren und genau also ähnlich
verhält es sich dann mit den ideen den
konkreten ideen ideen des baumes und so
weiter und so fort dies natürlich auch
erkenntnis grund und science grund des
jeweils konkret existierenden spannend
ist die frage warum platt und idee des
guten das gute nennt warum ist das gute
noch mal über dem sein
haben sie eine idee das ist eine ganz
ganz spannende frage gut ist doch was
ganz anderes als seien wir müssen wieder
zurück auf unser seminar thema kommen
was könnte der grund dafür sein dass
platt und jetzt von einer idee des guten
sprich des guten gerade agathon schreibt
auch noch mal hin das griechische wort
agathon hinten betont sie kennen agathe
den namen
was könnte der grund sein warum den
platte und die höchste idee die idee des
guten
was ist der grundgedanke dahinter warum
ist es gute das höchste wir werden das
in der kommenden sitzung auch nochmal
genauer behandelt wenn wir auf proteinen
den neue platonischer zu sprechen kommen
was könnte ein grund dafür sein
sozusagen das gute ist das höchste und
ich irgendwie das absolute oder sowas
das ist der unterschied zum beispiel zu
sagen es gibt das absolute und das gut
was ist der unterschied wenn man noch
sagen gut
hmm
gut sehr gut genau es ist eine wertung
enthalten ist eine eine normativität
könnte man es als eine norm eine
orientierung nicht nur dessen was
existiert sondern in abgeleiteten im
sinne oder einem bestimmten modus auch
dasjenige mit blick auf das was wir tun
sollen nicht nur bezogen auf das handeln
aber eben auch das ist eine ist gut man
könnte auch noch sagen es ist so ein
gedanke von ort und von ordnung also die
ordnung das was sich gehört die
orientierung auch die ordnung der kosmos
also da ist dieser gedanke der kirche
gedanke dass cosmos enthalten
cosmos bedeutet eigentlich schmuck auch
das schöne auch das schöne das gute das
waren
das ist alles im griechischen
letztendlich 1 also dahinter verbirgt
sich die orientierung
die normativität eine eine richtlinie
eine gewisse tendenz eine normative
tendenz dann aber auch eine ordnung an
ordnungs gedanke ein einheits gedanke
ein maßstabsgetreues endlich wie wir
auch noch später sind werden der gedanke
der wohl gefühlt also der kosmos ist
nicht chaos sondern in der welt hat
alles seine rechte ordnung das ist auch
dieser gedanke dieser idee des guten
das ist nicht einfach so chaotisch da so
durcheinander geht soll alles hat seinen
platz seine regeln ist natürlich ein
sehr optimistischer gedanke wir heutigen
sehen das bestimmt anders wenn sie auf
der quantenebene mal schauen wie da
alles chaotisch zufällig vor sich geht
oder wenn sie in die ganz großen
dimension gehen schwarze löcher dunkle
materie und so war das entzieht sich
unserer vernunft da können wir aber
heutzutage schwierigkeiten dann noch von
einem kosmos für eine ordnung zu
sprechen aber dennoch könnte man es tun
weil natürlich sich immer noch die frage
stellt was ist denn dann der grund von
allem was existiert selbst wenn es chaos
oder zufalls sein sollte kann diese
frage immer wieder stellen also
normativität ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
diese einheit normativität und jetzt
habe ich eine frage an sie
warum kennt platon keine idee des bösen
das wäre zum beispiel ein thema für
einen essay für diejenigen unter ihnen
die se schreiben müssen oder ein
protokoll sowie eine spannende frage
kann man auch in der hausarbeit machen
ist jetzt ein bisschen pointiert so dass
ich ihr zum essen raten würde da über
diese frage aber das hängt natürlich
viel mit kann jetzt überlegen sie mal
nach dem was wir gesagt haben warum
kennt platten keine idee des bösen oder
schlecht ist nur eine idee des guten
warum man die ganze ist eine schwierige
frage
jetzt machen wir kurz eine kleine
diskussions pause wir machen jetzt eine
pause
bitte diskutieren sie mit ihrem partner
mit ihrer partnerin kurz zwei minuten
über diese frage und dann ging mainz
planung wieder
[Musik]
wisst ihr was
da
ok
ich glaube wir können schluss machen ich
sehe sie sind mitten in der diskussion
jetzt wollen wir das ganze hier vorne
hinbringen aufs plenum bitte meldungen
was sind die gründe dafür dass platon
keine idee des guten des bösen oder des
schlechten hier in seiner schrift
politiker vertreten hat haben sie eine
idee bitte sie haben rege diskutiert
bestimmt interessante ergebnisse
bekommen gut gemacht könnte man auch
sagen vergänglich also mit spontanen
vergänglichen also damit ist gemeint
dass böse ist nur weil weil das böse
schlechte menschen gemacht vergänglich
was noch
ja
kein science grund kein erkenntnis-
grund so
ja es ist destruktiv nur destruktiv auch
noch destruktiv noch eine meldung
jetzt kann man sich doch fragen aber es
kann doch dennoch etwas existieren auch
wenn es destruktiv ist oder wenn es
vergänglich ist existiert ist doch das
genom vielleicht auf eine andere weise
es ist absolut ja
ok genau man könnte jetzt auch noch in
dieser metaphorik von licht und bleiben
sie mal jetzt hier in diesem modell noch
mal hier in diesem sollen gleiches
modell spielen sie das ganze mal durch
mit dem mit der idee des bösen was wäre
dann hier oben anzusetzen auf der
bildebene wäre da die sonne sondern des
bösen was müssen sie da metaphorisch
oder gleichnis mäßig hier in dieser
spalte eintragen und legen sie mal wenn
wir jetzt von die idee des bösen
sprechen ja ja das nichts oder jetzt mal
konkret ein bisschen schon richtig aber
das ist begrifflich er aber jetzt mal
mit bildlich gesprochen
genau dunkelheit sonst noch bemerken
na ja genau und es wächst nichts
bedenken sie denken sie an so
meteoriteneinschlag irgendwie von ein
paar hundert millionen jahren wo die
dinosaurier ausgestorben sind
da war die ganze sonne verdunkelt und
infolgedessen sind ganz viele arten
ausgestorben
wenn die sonne irgendwann mal erwischt
dann wird alles leben auf der erde auch
sterben nach einer bestimmten weile zeit
das heißt hier wäre vielleicht die
dunkelheit oder das chaos oder das ja
dass nichts wäre dann wieso er
begrifflicher das heißt es wäre kein
science grund weggegeben erkenntnis
grund natürlich auch nicht mehr
das wäre kann nichts leben schaffen dass
mehr da aber kann denn auch ich frage
nochmal kann nicht dort trotzdem das
nichtleben schaffende das leben
zerstören das nicht erkenntnis
ermöglicht hätte dennoch existieren wir
sprechen doch von ihm so dass nichts das
böse
okay gut guter punkt hier kann man sich
noch fragen wo wäre dann das böse
anzusiedeln hier sind eine idee kann es
nicht sein weil es nicht schafft und
nichts einheitliches ist wo würden sie
das böse hier auf dieser ebene hierzu
und logischen ebene vor ort sie hatten
wir zwar vorgeschlagen hierher lebewesen
gegenstände ja bitte
[Musik]
genau erdbeben von lissabon wir kommen
noch drauf leibnitz die aufklärung
das hat das ist doch eine realität dann
haben doch menschen gelitten
ja ja richtig das ist ein bisschen
verschoben
das stimmt aber es ist eben die gleichen
ebene also man könnte sagen das böse
wenn man es aber das schlechte wenn man
es irgendwie hier eintragen wollte
müsste man hier eintragen irgendwie hier
sind schatten hatten damals doch hier
schatten das ist ja das dunkle schatten
oder hier bilder also schein trugbilder
schatten dasjenige was uns täuscht das
wenige was uns hinter hinters licht
führt und wirklich wörtlich jetzt mal
gemeint hinters licht führte
genau es gibt gute gründe also dass man
jetzt glaube ich wichtige punkte die man
jetzt re konstruktiv an führen könnte
und platons implizite these dass es
keine idee des guten geben kann
zu begründen was nicht heißt wie sie
richtig sagen dass man das in frage
stellen kann wie sie es jetzt tun
man kann sie wohl sagen doch das böse
hat seine realität wurde hier gesagt ist
existiert faktisch es betrifft uns
existenziell
jetzt sah es noch schlecht wie erdbeben
oder sowas oder seines wirklich böse
handlung und böse motive die dann auch
zu büssen ja konsequenzen führen
die sind doch irgendwie auch ideell
gegeben ich habe das einplanen ich habe
mache mir gedanken
die haben was mit rationalität zu tun
das ist eine hochproblematische städte
plattform und man kann sagen plattform
ist ein idealist der sich am schönen und
guten orientiert und das böse und
schlecht er so ein bisschen ausblendet
hier dass das kommt dann hier so ganz
unten
das müssen wir mal so dahingestellt
lassen aber das ist ein problematischer
punkt beim plattform das haben sehr
viele auch erkannt dass nur als sind
diskussion folge sie sehen so könnte man
zb schreiben sie überlegen sich mögliche
gründe dafür dass platon jetzt hier
nicht nur eine idee des bösen spricht
sie können dann die gründe hier mal dann
im se auflisten wie wir sie getan haben
sie können natürlich auch gründe dagegen
wie der kommilitonen und kommilitoninnen
es getan haben anführen und dann am ende
vielleicht so ein fazit com also was
spricht für platons these ist es ja
keine ausdrücklich geäußerte these für
die implikationen der theorie dass es
keine idee des bösen geben kann oder
gibt und was die grille die platten
dafür dazu bewogen haben könnten und was
sind die gegen gründe die gegen so eine
auffassung sprechen und dann am ende
eigenes fazit das wäre interessant also
das haben jetzt diskutiert und jetzt
kommen wir zu seinem nachfolger
aristoteles
vierten jahrhundert vor christus und der
hat ein buch geschrieben denn die
komorische ethik und aus diesem buch
habe ich ihnen einen text zukommen
lassen wir haben jetzt wie üblich immer
noch leitfragen also was versteht
aristoteles unter gut klein geschrieben
und gut großgeschrieben kennt
aristoteles einen einheitlichen begriff
des guten
wie verhält sich seine theorie zu der
jeden platons das ist auch eine
spannende frage weil wir in diesem text
jetzt hier eine kritik an platon
entdecken werden auch wenn er den namen
nicht direkt nimmt dann kann man sich
wieder fragen vertritt aristoteles die
reine de unter logische oder
utilitaristische theorie des guten was
der onkologie und utilitarismus sind
habe ich letzte mal erklärt wie
verhalten sich gut und glückseligkeit
seine auffassung nach zueinander
das betrifft jetzt wieder die frage nach
dem höchsten gut die wir vorhin
diskutiert haben sind moralische
handlungen und glückseligkeit in einem
proportionalen verhältnis zueinander
oder nicht kant sagt wie wir noch sehen
werden kleiner vor blick kann zunächst
mal überhaupt nicht sondern
glückseligkeit sollte nie ein grund eine
motivation sein für gutes handeln
das ist sogar eher unmoralisch wenn wir
nach glück streben im handeln und
glauben dadurch gutes zu tun
das ist eher problematisch wobei dann
die idee des höchsten gutes die einheit
fordert aber jetzt nicht konkret in der
handlung situation so dann könne einfach
mal hier anfang ich lese mal vor jede
kunst und jede lehre ebenso jede
handlung und jeder im schluss scheint
irgendein gut agathon zu erstreben darum
hat man mit recht dass gute als
dasjenige bezeichnet wonach alles strebt
zeigt sich aber ein unterschied in den
zielen denn die einen sind tätigkeiten
die anderen sind bestimmte werke außer
ihm
wo es ziele außerhalb behandlungen gibt
da sind ihrer natur nach die werke
besser als die tätigkeiten dass nun
viele handlungen künste wissenschaften
gibt ergeben sich auch viele ziele zieht
der medizin ist die gesundheit der
schiffbau kunst das schiff der strategie
der sieg der ökonomik der reichtum wo
nun solche künstler einer einzigen
aufgabe untergeordnet sind wie etwa der
reitkunst die sattlerei und die anderen
der reitkunst im künste und wir die
reitkunst wiederum und die gesamte
kriegskunst der strategisch
untergeordnet ist und so andere unter
anderen in all diesen fällen sind die
ziele der leitenden künste insgesamt
vorzüglicher als die der untergeordneten
denn diese werden um jener willen
verfolgt läutet es ihnen ein dass es
also absolut zwecke gibt könnte man
sagen und relative zwecke oder
mittelbare zwecke mittelbare güter die
güter zu einem bestimmten ziel sind und
höher stufige güter ihr könnt das mal
uns etwas veranschaulichen
wir haben hier was hat er hier als
beispiel strategie strategie
wir sind sie was die strategie ist ja ja
die kriegskunst stratos ist das hier
und dieses ewig da steckt geomar in
griechischen das heißt führen also die
heeresführung das hier führen ja dann
müsste man sagen feldherrn kunst
letztendlich strategist der feldherr ja
kriegs uns muss dann ein engerer begriff
sein als strategisch guter hinweis muss
muss also strategisch muss weiter
gefasst sein
jetzt haben wir verschiedene unter
tätigkeiten wir haben hier
also der reitkunst ist dies hat ley
untergeordnet als wir haben hier
praktisch breit kunst und hier die
sattlerei und das ganze führt sagen hier
hoch hören also um hier eine gute
feldherrn kunst zu betreiben brauchen
wir die reitkunst und um die reitkunst
gut zu betreiben brauchen wir gute
settel sattel hat sattler
wir brauchen vielleicht auch noch gute
man kann das dann hier wiederum so
machen es gibt ja bestimmt eine andere
kunst hufschmied oder so schmid schmid
und so weiter
da kann man noch verschiedene andere
unterfüttern und es gibt eben eine
höhere kunst die alle anderen hinter
sich schließt natürlich kann man jetzt
noch sagen ja gut aber vielleicht gibt
es ja noch was drüber fragezeichen ist
die frage
das scheint jetzt aber erstmal der
endpunkt zu sein ist eigentlich ganz
klar es gibt mittelbare ziele die ziele
zu einem bestimmten zweck sind und es
gibt dann seinen höchsten höchstes gut
in anführungsstrichen jetzt nicht im
kantischen sinnen worauf alles zuläuft
was alles andere impliziert um jener
willen um jener wählen
lesen wir weiter wenn es nun ein ziel
des handels gibt dass wir um seiner
selbst willen wohl und das andere um
seinen willen wenn wir also nichts nicht
alles um eines anderen will er streben
denn so ging es sind unbegrenzte das ist
diese frage nach dem hier gibt's hier
noch was also weiter immer nur mittelbar
dann wäre das streben leer und sinnlos
ist auch eine interessante gibt es ein
gesandter gedanke dass jedes einzelne
streben muss letztendlich auf ein
endpunkt bezogen sein
wenn es immer weitergehen sich durch
reichen würde dann wäre es wer uns
sinnlos wenn es unbegrenzte gehen würde
also ein ziel ein fixpunkt und das ist
bei platon die idee des guten das ist
auch noch ein wichtiger punkt der platt
und gibt es einen letzten punkt auf den
alles hin zu läuft dass die idee des
guten also dass das ziel an sich
sozusagen dass der zweck an sich dann
ist es klar dass jenes das gute und
beste ist wird nun seine erkenntnis
nicht auch für das leben eine große
bedeutung haben und werden wir nicht wie
bogenschützen wenn wir dies vor augen
haben das richtige besser treffen können
wenn dies der fall ist wollen wir
versuchen im um bis zu erfassen was es
wohl sein mag und welche welcher
wissenschaft oder fähigkeit es angehört
und wird wohl annehmen dass es der
wichtigsten und leiten ssten
wissenschaft angehören
okay da haben wir jetzt mit so einem
superlativ zu tun mit dem höchsten
wichtigsten das wäre plattform die idee
des guten und jetzt sagt er bei
aristoteles man wird wohl annehmen dass
es die politische wissenschaft ist den
sie bestimmt welche wissenschaften in
den staaten vorhanden sein müssen welche
an jeder lernen muss und bis zu welchem
grade man sie lernen muss wir sehen auch
dass die angesehensten fähigkeiten ihr
untergeordnet sind aha es geht doch noch
höher
strategisch ökonomik rhetorik und andere
als es die politische wissenschaft die
hier noch drüber stehen also immer das
jetzt ist und darauf läuft das noch
hinaus
also es gibt noch weitere die strategie
die wiederum unter sich die reitkunst
und die sattlerei hat aber auch noch
ökonomisch also ökonomik und rhetorik
sind auf dieser ebene anzusiedeln
die geht dahin und die rhetorik auch
rhetorik auch die haben natürlich
wiederum unter sich gewisse weitere
sowie hier weitere künstler alles läuft
darauf hinaus da sie sich also der
übrigen praktischen wissenschaft
bedienen und gesetze darüber er lässt
was man zu tun und zu lassen habe so
dürfte wohl ihr ziel die ziele alle
anderen mit umfassen
dann wäre also dieses das gute für den
mensch mag nämlich auch das gute das
selbe sein für den einzelnen und den
start erscheint es doch größer
unvollkommener zu sein das gute für den
staat ergreifen und zu bewahren
erfreulich ist es zwar schon bei einen
einzigen menschen schöne und göttliche
aber für völker und staaten haben sie
jetzt hier schon so ein unterschied
feststellen können zu platons idee des
guten wenn man so ganz mag wir kommen
noch genauer drauf aristoteles führt
noch die unterscheidenden gründe an aber
bereits jetzt erscheint das schon mal
ein bisschen klarer
genau da ist so ein touristischer
konsequenz ii allis tischer gedanke
dahinter also ein bisschen zweck mittel
rationalität
das ist ein punkt ein anderer punkt ist
es ist viel lebensweltliche das höchste
ist in der gesellschaft in der konkreten
praxis im handel im agieren in der
interaktion von lebendigen wesen wie es
menschen einmal sind als er verortet das
ganze lebensweltlich konkrete situation
der völker der menschen zu einer
bestimmten zeit sagt die politische
wissenschaft das ist dasjenige was das
höchste ziel ist weil alle anderen
wissenschaften die alle anderen
tätigkeiten ja unter sich vereinen
sie müssen sich das ganz konkret
vorstellen hier ist ja nicht die
sattlerei ist jetzt ja nichts abstraktes
letztendlich sondern hier kommt
natürlich dann konkret die sattler kunst
kunst das herstellen das konkrete
handwerk das handwerk das handwerk also
hier macht jemand ein sattel der braucht
dann bestimmt wieder unter sich einen
gerber der das leder für den sattel so
zubereitet dann die gerber kunst die
gerberei die kommt dann noch darunter
nicht nur für diese dinge ist die gerber
kunst kann auch noch für andere lieder
waren dienen aber dann kommt plötzlich
derjenige der dann also tierhäute also
abzieht und trocknet und wäscht und
daraus macht dann erst der sattler den
sattel als sie können sich wirklich die
konkrete handlung die konkrete praxis
als so ein teil moment vorstellen als
ein handlungs moment was in letzer hin
sich dann auf die politische
wissenschaft hinzu strebt
das heißt jetzt nicht doch das heißt es
eine jedes handwerk jedes einzelne jede
mögliche tätigkeit muss sagt platt und
letztendlich wenn ich ihnen recht
versagt aristoteles muss letztendlich
auf diese oder unter diese politische
wissenschaft sind wir mal im eingeordnet
werden können und ihr untergeordnet
werden können weil die politische
wissenschaft alles andere unter sich
vereint und letztendlich zusammenfasst
bündelt könnte man auch sehen sie das
anders gibt es noch andere auffassung ja
gut sie haben hingewiesen auf die praxis
ich habe es erst mal ganz allgemein die
praxis genannt also preises ist ein noch
konkreter begriff der einfach nur das
hervorbringen das erzeugen meint sie
hier sind hat das immer was mit
hervorbringen zu tun
hier wird das leder hervorgebracht in
einer weise dass es weiterverarbeitet
werden kann
und es ist richtig dass sie darauf
hinweisen dass es ja nach platon noch
verschiedene lebensformen gibt wie es in
diesem text heißt bios ist der begriff
des lebens grundsätzlich hier wird
übersetzt mit lebensform
es gibt eben nicht nur die poetische
existenz weise sondern auch noch die
betrachtete die theoretischen die
tätigkeit des philosophen müssen also
schauen ob jetzt wirklich alles alle
formen von aktivitäten von strömungen in
der politischen wissenschaft münden dazu
lesen wir mal weiter
da also jede erkenntnis und jeder
entschluss nach irgendeinem gute strebt
und das ist auch noch ein wichtiger
punkt dieses streben nach dem ziel das
ist das teuerste los ziel gibt noch die
technologie ist die tatsache oder die
theorie des strebens die tatsache dass
alles strebt was lebendig ist und das
alles obwohl es mit ost auf hört könnte
man denken ist der teller ist aber dass
teller ist neutrum obwohl es mit was
aufhören obwohl die meisten wird im
griechischen mythos auf für männlich
sind
es ist hier neutrum castello also noch
irgendeine gute strebt das ist die
gemeine theologie wonach wird nach
unserer meinung die politischen
wissenschaft streben und welches ist das
oberste aller praktischen güter im namen
stimmen wohl die meisten überein
glückseligkeit nennen ist die leute und
die gebildeten als wir müssen hier oben
noch normal glückseligkeit beschreiben
heißt man wie der griechische begriff
begriff für glückseligkeit ist ja genau
da steckt das wort ist einfach nur gut
und das wort dreimal dem mond kann man
sagen ist ein geist ein schutzgeist also
das gut gut begeistert sein oder sona
das gut
glückseligkeit ist die deutsche
übersetzung einen guten geist haben es
ja vielleicht fällt ihnen noch etwas ein
glückseligkeit ist nicht genau das
wortwörtliche übersetzung äquivalent von
einem guten geist geleitet zu sein
ja so was genau genau also das ist das
ist einfach wieder so ein bisschen
bekommt bisschen metaphysik hinein also
es ist ja es ist nicht nur so ein gefühl
also nicht nur ein gefühl glückseligkeit
seien es mehr na da ist eine gewisse
leitung in einem macht vielleicht auch
man hat sich der richtigen macht
vielleicht angeschlossen oder man wird
durch die richtige macht gelingt es
immer schwierig aber es ist nicht nur so
ne glückseligkeit wie man jetzt sagt ach
jetzt freue ich mich mal so jetzt bin
nicht glücklich oder so das ist eine
gesteigerte form intensiver reform
was aber die glückseligkeit zeit darüber
streiten sie und die leute sind nicht
derselben meinung wie die weißen und das
muss irgendwie fällt das ganze falsch
was steht dabei in dem text wie die
wilden oder weißen das hat es wohl
falsch kopiert jetzt auf seite das müsst
ihr auf seite im umbruch seite 13 seite
14 sein
das stück dabei ihnen text hansi weißen
gerhards das falsch kapiert wie die
weißen jede nämlich verstehen darunter
etwas sichtbares und greifbares wie lust
reichtum oder ehre der eine dienste
andere jenes oftmals auch ein und
derselbe verschiedene er krank ist meint
die gesundheit wenn der arm ist in
reichtum
da sie aber ihre eigenen unwissenheit
bewusst sind bewundern sie jene die
etwas großes und ihr verständnis über
steigendes sagen einige meinten es gebe
neben diesen vielen gütern ein gutes an
sich und für sich dass auch die ursache
des klubs 1 all derer anderen güter wäre
alle ansichten nun zu prüfen ist wohl
ihr sinnlos wir dürfen uns wohl auf jene
beschränken den verbreitetsten sind und
einigermaßen begründe zu sein scheint
wer ist jetzt hier gemeint der der hand
auffassung ist
das
neben diesen vielen gütern ein gutes an
und für sich ist das auch die ursache
des gutscheins alle anderen güter wäre
wer ist damit leider ein gutes an sich
das wäre zu einfach die frage betont
genau platon er nennt ihn jetzt nicht
ausdrücklich dass ein schüler von platon
sie wissen alle aristoteles hat sich
durchaus kritisch mit seinem lehrer
platten auseinandergesetzt
die waren sich nicht in allen hinsichten
einig sie könnten also zum beispiel auch
für eine hausarbeit oder fein se das
thema willen platon oder aristoteles
wäre es überzeugende oder aristoteles
kritik an platin oder ein vergleich der
idee des guten und der harmonie das wäre
ein mögliches se oder auch haus
arbeitszimmern als er sagt es ist es ist
jedenfalls gut ist relativ je nach
situation in der ich mich befinde ist
für mich das höchste gut etwas
verschiedenes nein wenn ich krank bin
möchte ich die gesundheit und so weiter
und sofort gibt es da noch was was
absolut also nicht nur relativ auf
bestimmte zustände als gutes an sich
gelten kann
nicht ohne grund scheint man das gute
oder die glückseligkeit an den
lebensformen bio das bios abzulesen der
bios der bios also das leben der bios
choral bio abzulesen die mehrzahl der
leute und die routen wählen die lust
hätten sie kennen alle das wort hedonist
hedonisten sind menschen die nur nach
der lust ihr leben ausrichten hedonist
darum schätzen sie auch das leben des
genusses das sind hedonisten es gibt
nämlich vor allem drei hervorstechende
lebensformen die eben genannte die
hedonistische lebensform also bios wie
auch immer hedone ticos vielleicht gibt
es das es gibt die hedonistische
lebensform dann gibt es die politische
und das ist jetzt das was wir hier haben
politische wissenschaft darauf streben
die ganzen hin und dann gibt es noch die
betrachten worauf der kommilitone
hingewiesen hat die den bios
theoretikers den theoretischen
betrachtenden und nicht politisch
handelnden lebensvollzug die große menge
erweist sich als völlig sklaven artig da
sie ja das leben des vorzieht das ist
das juristische leben gibt es also hier
etwas gutes zu essen dann gehe ich
danach und habe ich jetzt wieder durst
dann geht's danach dann bin ich müde
dann möchte ich schlafen habe ich wieder
hunger dann geht es dahin soll das ist
alles sehr abwertend von aristoteles
gibt es auch bei platon auch immer die
menge ja das ist also die große menge
los oder was auch immer hier das ist der
pöbel es wirklich das ist ein bisschen
arrogant oder edith er gedacht aber so
waren die damals eben
und es ist natürlich auch ein fünkchen
wahrheit enthalten aber das ist doch
alles sehr schematisch hier gibt es die
großen menge und dann gibt es die
wenigen elitären ist ein bisschen
egoistisch aber es ist natürlich auch
eine erkenntnis dahinter dass man eben
aufpassen muss sich nicht nur von den
listen und den neigungen treiben zu
lassen weil man dann völlig sklaven
artig ist und eben nicht mehr frei ist
also das thema freiheit spielt ja auch
eine große rolle also wir können den
begriff des guten auch freiheits
theoretisch interpretieren das höchste
gut
das stärkste group ist dasjenige gut was
uns in freiheit setzt und was uns nicht
versklavt und uns in unseren neigungen
abhängig machen sie kommen aber zu einer
einiger rechtfertigung das ist das leben
des viehs sagt ja sie kommen aber zu
einiger rechtfertigung da es vielen
unter den mächtigen ähnlich ergeht wie
sah dann ab 1
kennen sie den namen es in der mehr
bekannt vorgekommen dass es ein d'azur
ist könig die gebildeten und energischen
menschen wählen die ehre denn dies kann
man als das ziel des politischen lebens
bezeichnen aber es scheint doch
oberfläche sein als das was wir suchen
den die ehre liegt wohl ihr in den
ehrenden als in den gärten von guten
aber vermuten wir dass es den menschen
eigen ist und nicht leicht verloren
gehen kann
jetzt müssen wir uns noch ein bisschen
genauer diskutieren und jetzt schreiben
wir uns nochmal hier die drei
lebensformen auf als über sich
wir haben drei lebensformen sagen die
noch mal kurz was ist die erste
lebensform wie soll ich sie nennen also
die unterste sagen wir machen das jetzt
auch hier mal gestuft wir beginnen hier
ja hedonismus nennen wir einfach mal mit
der reihe nach was kommt danach wie soll
man es nennen sie können gerne auch eine
übersetzung anbieten
das kommt darüber politisches leben
vielleicht können wir mal politisches
leben und ganz oben
theoretisches leben oder summe könnte
man sagen ja wir kommen da noch ein
bisschen hat jetzt ja erst nur diese
zwei unteren eigentlich behandelt
und was ist jetzt hier hedonismus was
ist der inhalt des hedonismus was soll
ich hin schreiben und als einfach gibt
die punkte die diese lebensform aus
zeichen und auch problematisch
erscheinen lassen genau lustbefriedigung
und was ist damit einhergehend hat es
genannt im oberen teil des zitats
abhängigkeit
das ist auch hetero nomi ist das
fremdwort also hält also fremd
gesetzgebung hätte romy das klare reine
unfreiheit und noch ein punkt was sagt
ihr noch welcher lebensform eine dass
das ist praktisch das leben des st
ok dann ja
gut sehr gut ja genau wir können hier so
eine bedürfnispyramide ein zeichen als
hintergrund und wir sehen ganz oben bei
maslow kommt die transzendenz daran kann
ich mich noch erinnern
und so geht es auch im also maslow hat
natürlich von aristoteles oder von
dieser tradition nicht aristoteles von
was läuft aber das ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig dass ich dass das so läuft das
ist also eine zuspitzung und sie haben
insofern auch noch zurecht aufmaße lauf
hingewiesen weil sich die frage stellt
ob man nur mal so existieren kann also
nur in diesem bereich ob das überhaupt
möglich ist oder ob nicht um so zu leben
dass untere schon gegeben sein muss das
ja die einsicht bei maslow die müssen ja
befriedigt sein und erst dann kommt als
krone auf die basis diese transzendenz
und wir müssen uns jetzt fragen bei
genau hinschauen ob bei platon auch beim
theoretischen leben das untere gegeben
sein muss die befriedigung dieser
unteren lebensformen oder ob es dieses
theoretische leben als solches abgelöst
von den unteren stufen gibt
genau wie aristoteles platon wir müssen
es immer vergleichen
das ist gut und genau und es gibt auch
bei aristoteles und platon ja diese
seelen stufen haben sie sicherlich auch
schon mal gehört das entspricht ziemlich
genau dem bei aristoteles gibt es die
näher seele das ist also das was aus
lust und so geht dann gibt es noch die
wahrnehmen der seele
das entspricht jetzt nicht ganz dem aber
das gibt dann die intellektuelle die
intellektuellen serienteil gibt es auch
noch bei aristoteles platon gibt es drei
als es bei aristoteles sind es zehn
stufen des todes treten auf eine basis
deswegen sind sie gerade auf die
richtige richtung treten auf einer basis
weitere stufen auf die immer der unteren
stufe bedürfen
die sind implikation verhältnis das
obere impliziert immer das untere
während das untere nicht dass opera
impliziert und bei platon ist es so dass
es nicht mehr drei säle stufen gibt es
dann drei sälen teile ja und da muss man
sich fragen wie die sich genauer
verhalten gibt es ganz oben das logistik
das vernünftige dann gibt es noch das
mut hafte timo ids das würde glaube ich
durchaus er sagt er vergleicht es mit
schichten eines staates als oben sind
die philosophen könige das sind die
reinen denker gibt es die wächter das
sind die mut haften und weiß noch jemand
wie die unterste der untersten teil weil
platon heißt das ist das ja genau wie
take on das begehren de der begehren der
seelen teil und das haben wir ja hier
auch beim händler des ist so hedonismus
das ist einfach nur lustbefriedigung
begierde lust
also es gibt ja immer so eine
dreiteilung das ist eine lange tradition
platon wenn ich es recht zäh bringt
diese seelen teile nicht in so eine
differenzierte ordnung wie es
aristoteles macht platon sagt dann der
die das logistikern also das höchste
seelen vermögen oder höchsten teil muss
die anderen sälen teile anleihen also er
muss das mut haft
und das begehren de der seele
kontrollieren weil sonst gibt es eine
unordnung sonst gibt es ein chaos am
start
aber es ist nicht so differenziert über
aristoteles so was sagte aristoteles
über das politische leben das kann man
jetzt hier anführen
ihre energisches trifft sehr gut mit dem
thema leds also tumors ist der mut das
mut hafte energisch swr wehmut haften so
ein bisschen das trifft es passt mit den
platonischen eigentlich sehr gut überein
mit diesem mittleren und was jetzt der
nachteil dieser lebensform genau wie der
reform von hetero- nomi genau geben sie
mal konkretes beispiel wenn ich jetzt
nach ihre strebe wenn er mein höchstes
gut ist inwiefern bin ich daran abhängig
genau genau für dich wichtig sie kennen
diese fälle wo jemand eine person ihr
ist wo einer person erst nach ihrem tod
ehre zuteil wird
die frage hat sie da noch was davon also
konkrete sich ihre nachfahren haben wir
es davon ihre nachkommen dies schon je
nachdem wie man auch die person
definiert erstreckt sich die person in
ihren interessen auf die nächste
generation ist eine spannung frage
person existiert ja nur für sich
genommen schon steht und bezügen die
synchron aber auch diakon und vielleicht
sogar noch transzendent sind über ihr
leben überschreiten
zum beispiel könnte die person sagen
meine lieben kinder in diesem leben habe
ich die iren nicht erfahren aber wartet
nur noch zehn jahre wenn ich nicht mehr
da bin dann werdet ihr bestimmt von
meinen ruhm viel nutzen haben und das
könnte auch die option dass sowas noch
eintritt könnte auch der person die das
nicht mehr erlebt irgendwie freude
bereiten
diese möglichkeit weil sie es schon ab
sieht die gesellschaft ist noch nicht
bereit dafür meine großartigkeit zu
erkennen aber in zehn jahren ist es
soweit und dann kriegen meine kinder
also ehre ist timos team aus dem
rtl-team also das steckt kommt vom
griechischen einschätzen einschätzen
thema ist die wertschätzung also auch
die ehre die in einem staat einer person
zu kommt ja ihre ämter ämter sind
ehrenämter in der antike sind politische
ämter häufig ehrenämter für die man kein
geld bekommt also sind nicht
berufspolitiker dieser berufstypische
des berufspolitikers ist was neues in
der damaligen zeit hatte man genug geld
wenn man politisch tätig wurde und
konnte auch erst politisch tätig werden
wenn man schon bereits genug geld hatte
zwar eine ehrenbezeugung auch ein ideal
also das stück dieses diese thema das
wäre diese griechische begriff ich
glaube dass er nicht so verschieden von
uns im heutigen begriff der ehre ist
ihre ist ja auch ein sehr
problematischer begriff natürlich ne
sehr lang aber ich denke guter punkt ist
hier bezogen auf die ämter ihre
institutionelle ehre als er jetzt die
inter subjektiv staatlich bemessen wird
ja so was also immer im kontext der
staatlichkeit ihre würde ich sagen
ok also auch das ist es nicht
weil sie ist doch oberflächlicher was
auch immer oberfläche geht es hier
griechischen haben sie gerade im
kritischen text vor sich können sie mir
schon etwas oberflächlicher hier ist
können wir schauen hier wenn es jemand
hat kann ja mal vergleichen was da steht
oberflächlicher ja den die ihre liegt
wohl hier in den ehrenden also in denen
die die ehre da bringen zu den geehrten
der der geehrt wird der ist abhängig von
einer gesellschaft die seinen wert
erkennt und die dann auch noch die
institution der ehe ein zu konkret
irgendwelche ihren ämter oder konkret
welche auszeichnungen für mich eine
veranstaltung wo irgendwie einen pokal
oder sowas überreicht wird ja wenn es
das nicht gibt diesen kontext dann ist
es nichts mit der ehre
darauf können wir uns nicht verlassen
das ist das problem
und sie kann auch leicht verloren gehen
und kann seine ehre verspielen ja
entehrt werden seine ehre verlieren wenn
man etwas anderes tut das nicht so gut
ist dann verliert man sie vielleicht in
den augen der gesellschaft das können
andere politische umstände eintreten in
den ich plötzlich nicht mehr ihre
genieße das bild sehr abhängig von
äußeren situationen und das kann es
nicht sein wenn wir vom wirklich vom
guten als solchen sprechen also könnte
man vielleicht die tüchtigkeit als das
letzte ziel der politischen lebens von
auffassen
aber selbst sie ist unvollkommen den
offenbar das denkbar dass man im besitze
der tüchtigkeit auch schlafen oder sein
leben lang untätigkeit sein kann
man kann außerdem mit ihr missgeschick
erleiden und das größte unglück kommen
wäre so leeb den wird niemand glückselig
nennen außer eben um seine behauptung
zurück die dritte lebensform ist die
betrachten die theoretiker wie aus
theoretikers sie werden wir im
nachfolgenden untersuchen
die kaufmännische lebensraum hat etwas
gewaltsames an sich und offensichtlich
ist der reichtum nicht das gesuchte gute
denn er ist nur als mittel zu anderen
zwecken zu gebrauchen
darum wird man wohl ihr die oben
genannten dinge als ziele annehmen denn
diese werden um ihrer selbst willen
geschätzt doch auch sie scheint nicht
das gesucht sein ob schon viele
argumente zu ihren gunsten angeführt
sind
also wir müssen doch die gründe dafür
angeben warum hier oben das theoretische
leben nur das eigentlich gute verbürgen
kann
dies wollen wir nun lasst wichtiger ist
es wohl den begriff des universalen zur
untersuchung und sich zu fragen wie
gemein zeit freilich widerstrebt eine
solche untersuchung da uns befreundete
männer die ideen eingeführt haben sie
können sich schon überlegen wird diese
befreundeten männer sind es scheint aber
besser und eine pflicht der wahrheit
gegen wird es sein
auch die eigenen empfindungen nicht zu
schulen zumal da wir philosophen sind
sie kennen bestimmt an dem spruch plato
amico smaghis amica veritas platin ist
mein freund
eine größere freundin aber ist die
wahrheit glaube dass dieser spruch 'wenn
ich ganz sicher dass der hier zu finden
ist dass das die grundlage dafür ist
das ist es das ist es denn da wir dabei
uns lieb sind liebt es ist amicus freund
lateinisch das ist der spruch na also
das ist aristoteles gegen plattform das
ist ein satz den man häufig in der
redewendung die man häufig anfühlt wenn
man sagt ich sympathisiere mit der
diesen menschen mit diesem denker mit
dieser denkerin sehr aber ein schritt
höher ist eben die wahrheit selbst wenn
ich diese person sehr schätze und sie
eine autorität darstellt kann oder wer
auch immer oder platin in diesem fall
letztendlich müsse man halt doch nach
der wahrheit gehen und die person steht
im hintergrund auch wenn es eine ganz
bedeutende denker ist das ist dieser
dieser stelle glaub ich zu dürfen wir
erst noch nicht verantworten die
wahrheit so dürfen wir es doch
verantworten zur um die wahrheit
vorzuziehen also die wahrheit ist der
person die uns lieb ist im denken
vorzuziehen
diejenigen die diese lehre aufgebracht
haben haben überall da keine ideen
angenommen wo sie von einem früher und
später redeten das ist das was sie sagen
das vergängliche das physische darum
haben sie auch keine gemein gesamtidee
der zahlen aufgestellt das ist auch
interessant zahlen sind nach platon
ideen und jede zahl hat eine idee warum
weil die einzelne zahlen nicht vergeht
zahl ist was konstantes das gute aber
findet sich in den kategorien der wesen
hat die qualität und der relation das an
sich aber und die wesenheit ist ihre
natur nach früher als die relation denn
diese gleicht einem neben schößling und
einem zusatz zum sein denn es kann also
keine idee geben die alle diese
kategorien gemeinsam um greift
ok fahren sehen sie da schon so eine
kritik an platons idee des guten
als er sagt hier das gute findet sich in
verschiedenen kategorien platin sagt er
dass gute als solches gibt es nun eine
idee jetzt sagt platon aristoteles der
auch diesen kategorien unterschieden hat
es findet sich geben in der wesenheit
der qualität unter relation aber unter
diesen kategorien eben in der wesenheit
vorrangig weil alles andere abgeleitet
ist
und dann ist eben hier entscheidend es
kann keine idee geben die alle diese
kategorien gemeinsam und greift und das
wäre ja bei platon der fall
diese absolut idee die alles gute und
dass ich fast sagt aristoteles nein das
gute kann noch verschiedenen kategorien
noch unterschieden werden und diese
kategorien sind logisch voneinander
unabhängig in einer gewissen weise und
die idee des guten kann diese kategorie
nicht logisch nicht umgreifen spannende
these nein aber sie sehen aristoteles
ist doch durchaus differenzierter aber
irgendwie auch lebenspraktische so
müssen dann am ende schauen was jetzt
hier überzeugen da ist
ich lese weiter ferner davon guten
ebenso viele bedeutungen ausgesagt
werden wie vom sein denn das findet sich
in der kategorie der wesenheit wie gott
oder geist in der qualität wie die
tugenden der qualität wie das rechte maß
in der relation wie das brauchbare in
der zeit wie die rechte gelegenheit es
ist kairos haben es schon hört kairos
der rechten augenblick in dem raume wie
der gesunde aufenthaltsort und
dergleichen so gibt es da offenbar kein
universales das allen gemeinsam und 1
denn sonst würde man von ihm nicht in
allen kategorien sondern nur in einer
sprechen wäre da es von dem zu einer
idee gehörigen auch nur eine
wissenschaft gibt so würde es auch nur
eine wissenschaft von allen guten geben
nun gibt es aber viele sogar von dem was
unter eine
einzige kategorie fällt wie etwa die
rechte gelegenheit im krieg und der
strategie behandelt wird in der
krankheit von der medizin und wie die
wissenschaft des rechten maßes bei der
nahrung die medizin ist bei der
körperlichen anstrengung die gymnastik
man wird auch fragen was sie eigentlich
mit dem begriffe des an sich meinen da
ja jeder da ja der mensch an sich und
der mensch unter denselben begriff
fallen nämlich den des menschen sofern
beide mensch sind unterscheiden sie sich
nicht dasselbe gilt auch vom guten
sofern es gutes ist auch wird das gute
an sich nicht darum hier gut sein weil
es ewig ist wie auch das dauerhaft
sichtweise ist als das nur einen tag
stehende ja hier führt jetzt glatt
aristoteles nochmal seine gründe weiter
aus warum er nicht wie platon s getan
hatte von einer homogenen einheitlichen
idee des guten ausgeht können sie
nochmal diese argumente von aristoteles
wiedergeben paraphrasieren was sagt er
jetzt zügig der aristotelischen sich
dass es ein einheits begriff des guten
die idee des guten gibt eine kategorie
hmm
genau diese relativität des guten ist
hier jedenfalls ein spiel genau und auch
noch die kategoriale verschiedenheiten
es gibt eben das gute in der kategorie
der wesenheit fiel in der zweiten zeile
hier essenz die qualität die qualität
und die relation
es sind verschiedene kategorien die es
nicht mehr erlauben nur von einer
einzigen kategorie der idee des guten
ausgehen gibt verschiedene hinsichten
also nicht nur verschiedene situationen
den verschiedenes gut ist sondern wir
verwenden gut in ganz verschiedenen
kategorie aller verschiedenheit zb neben
der richtige zeitpunkt für sagen der
gute zeitpunkt damit weil mir was
anderes als wir von guten qualitäten
sprechen ob jetzt ein guter raum ob das
auch eine andere bedeutung von raum ist
da bin ich so ein bisschen skeptisch
aber ich glaube er hat schon zurecht
gezeigt dass verschiedene kategorien
stufen des guten gibt die nicht
aufeinander abbildbar oder zurückführbar
sind es sind ihre bedeutungen von gut
das ist der punkt es ist ihr reduziere
diesen logisch voneinander unabhängig
kategorie ahl verschieden
wir kriegen die nicht auf den einheits
begriff sagt aristoteles
dennoch kann man sich frage aber warum
nennen wir dann alles gut auch wenn es
für die verschiedenen kategorien
verbindet und gibt es nicht doch so ein
überbegriff des guten
selbst wenn wir der differenzierung
haben gegen das von uns gesagte könnte
aber ein gewand werden dass nämlich jene
theorie gar nicht von jedem guten gelten
wolle
sind das nur das um seiner selbst willen
erstrebte und geschätzte als eine idee
aufgefasst werde und gegen das wenige
was jenes hervorbringen oder irgendwie
bewahren oder das gegensätzliche ab wäre
nur im hinblick auf jenes und einem
anderen sinne gut hieße das gute hätte
dann offensichtlich eine doppelte
bedeutung das eine wäre gut an sich das
andere im hinblick auf jenes trennen wir
also das gute an sich von dem nützlichen
und prüfen ob es nun als eine idee
aufgefasst werden kann
was für güter wird man aber als güter an
sich ansetzen
etwa jene die auch für sich allein
erstrebt werden wie das denken sehen und
bestimmte freuden und ihren auch wenn
wir dies und eines anderen willen suchen
so mag man es doch zudem an sich guten
rechnen
oder wäre es überhaupt nichts anderes
außer der idee selber dann wäre sie aber
eine form ohne gehalt
also hier kritik an platon wenn es nur
die idee selbst ist wäre das eine form
ohne gehalt das wäre dann nur abstrakt
also trennen wir das gute hier trennen
wir das gut an sich von dem nützlichen
gibt es also etwas gutes an sich ohne
dass es nützlich sein muss also
aristoteles spricht für diese doppelten
bedeutung gut kann bedeuten dass gut an
sich und das instrumentelle gut das gut
mit blick auf einen bestimmten zweck
weiter
wenn aber auch jene dinge an sich gut
sind wird man zeigen müssen dass
derselbe begriff des guten in ihnen
allen sichtbar wird sowie im schnee und
im bleiweiß der begriff des weißen die
begriffe von ihre erkenntnisse und loos
sind aber verschieden gerade darin
sofern sie güter sind das gute alte das
gemeinsam während als eine idee
aufgefasst werden könnte existiert nicht
also es ist so seine ja ist die frage
wie man das jetzt nennt kann matti
kalisch haben sie nie die wie könnte mir
jetzt gute nennen ist es jetzt eine
analoge redeweise von gut oder ist es
sogar eine app wie vogue aktion von gut
sie kennt dieses spiel teekesselchen
teekesselchen kennen sie also bank bank
kennen sie doch bank bank also die geld
institution und die sitzgelegenheit das
ist eine ecke wo kation es sind
dieselben wörter dasselbe laut bild aber
es hat mir verschiedene bedeutung ist
jetzt mit dem guten hier genau so dass
wir gut gut gut wie bank bank als gut
gut wie bank bank sagen selbe laut bild
selber das wort aber verschiedene
bedeutung oder ist es nicht ganz so
extrem wie bei einer ecke wo kation
sondern gut hat immer noch eine ähnliche
bedeutung aber nur in anderen hinsicht
das wäre dann so eine analoge begriffs
verwendung also was würden sie hier ihr
neigen analoge denke ich auch
ähnlich sagt auch aristoteles müssen die
noch genau nachgehen sagt auch dass sein
wird in verschiedener hinsicht ausgesagt
dass sein sein kann auch ganz
verschiedenes bedeuten ohne dass es
jetzt eine ecke wo kation ist belegen
sie mal die verschiedenen bedeutungen
von sein
wie kann ich sein verwenden in welchen
kontexten bestimmt drei verbindungs
weisen von sein
eine finden sie doch bestimmt ja genau
ich bin hier ist ihre existenz
ja ja ich bin so und so
ja ja das wäre das prädikat tiefe dann
also diese seien als populist sagen ja
also ich bin so und so also medikation
coppola gibt es ein drittes es gibt noch
zwei weitere sogar überlegen sie mal ich
sage das ist aber so es ist so
wenn sie dieses ist besonders betonen
dass es ist aber so ja das wäre noch ein
weiteres in der jetzt nicht mit dem
beispiel gemeint ist aber völlig richtig
wie zum beispiel ist b ja also identität
ist auch noch möglich sind von sein
genau es ist dasselbe wie zweite dritte
und jetzt noch mal zurück auf meinem
beispiel gesagt es ist aber so betonen
sie hat dass es so ist sie betonen also
nicht sie betonen die existenz einer
sache aber auch noch das tatsächliche
vorliegen also sw rita tiefes sein
es ist der fall der fall sein dass also
es hat mindestens vier verwendung
speisen und so könnte man jetzt ohne
dass die ecke wo kationen sind also es
hat schon was mit mir zu tun
und so könnte man jetzt auch nach
aristoteles gut aufpassen
anna logischen sinne aber er sie sehen
jetzt also sehr differenziert während
plattform so diese große idee annimmt
aber wie ist es denn zu verstehen denn
viele gute scheint doch nicht zufällig
dass viele gute scheint doch nicht
zufällig wird selben namen zu haben als
sind es provokationen sozusagen ist es
etwa darum weil es von einem herkommt
oder insgesamt auf eines hin zielt oder
er in der weise der analogie
das ist also diese frage jetzt hier in
dieser weise ist das was im körper das
sehvermögen ist der seele der geilsten
einem anderen wiederum ein anderes aber
diesen punkt müssen wir jetzt wohl
fallen lassen und darüber genaueres
auszusagen dürfte einem anderen bereiche
der philosophie angemessener sein
dasselbe gilt auch von der frage nach
der idee auch wenn das gute existiert
das ein assist und allgemein ausgesagt
wird oder dass abgetrennt und an und für
sich besteht so ist es doch klar dass
dieses gute für den menschen weder zu
verwirklichen noch zu erwerben ist
nun ist es aber ein solches was wir
suchen vielleicht könnte man meint ihr
kenntnis des abgetrennten guten böte
einen nutzen im hinblick auf die zu
erwerbenden und zu verwirklichen und
güter
wir hätten jenes nämlich wie eine art
vorbild vor augen und würden damit auch
das gute für uns besser erkennen und
wenn wir es erkennen dann auch erlangen
was sagte jetzt hier noch eine platte an
dass die idee des guten des absoluten er
spricht jetzt hier von dem abgetrennten
abgetrenntes gutes hier ein abgetrenntes
gutes jahr
genau eine bluse perspektive könnte man
eine orientierung nach kant wäre das
eine transzendentale idee kann spricht
auch von ideen das wäre aber nur eine
idee als eine ein vorbild und
orientierung
das ist aber nicht mit der platonische
sinne von idee des guten weil bei platin
ist es ja so dass die idee des guten der
grund ist es die designs grund und
erkenntnis kommen und nicht nur so eine
orientierung wo wir hin stricken können
also hier sagte wir brauchen die idee
für uns sagt aristoteles diese
überlegung hat zwar einige
wahrscheinlichkeit widerspricht aber dem
tatbestand bei den wissenschaften und
alle zwar streben nach irgend ein guter
und kümmern sich um das was dann mangelt
und der noch lassen sie die erkenntnis
dieses guten ansicht bereit
er ist aber nicht glaubhaft dass
sämtliche spezialisten ein derartiges
hilfsmittel nicht kennen und nicht
andere vermissen würden
man sieht auch nicht was ein weber oder
schreiner nutzen in seiner eigenen kunst
haben soll dass er das gute an sich
kennt oder wie ein böser arzt oder fällt
er wird wenn er dieses guten betrachtet
hat es scheint ja auch der arzt nicht
einmal die gesundheit an sich zu suchen
sondern die gesundheit des menschen oder
vielleicht eher die gesundheit dieses
bestimmten menschen denn er hält den
einzeln hier sehen sie ganz ganz
konzentriert den unterschied zwischen
aristoteles und platon glatt und geht es
immer um das universal und das allgemein
die idee an sich das abgetrennte wie
ihre studios seien gut beraten wird
natürlich bestreiten dass die idee des
guten das abgetrenntes ist würde gerade
nichts sagen das ist abgetrennt die
schwebt da so um sie für sich herum zu
jedes guten ist das angebundene an sich
die idee des guten ist die bedingung von
allen verbundenen aber nicht abgetrennt
weil die idee in kausal verhältnissen
steht zu allem anderen der welt sie ist
der science konnte erkenntnis grund nach
platten
deswegen ist die aristotelische
bezeichnung als abwehr trennendes nicht
ganz richtig weil die kausalität ketten
oder qualitäts bezüge dadurch gekappt
das ist ja für platon ganz wichtig aber
also dass er sagt es geht um den einzeln
und das individuum das ist typisch
aristoteles konkrete situation konkretes
kunst als letztes zitat dann müssen
schluss machen wir wollen abermals auf
das gesuchte gute zurück kommen und
fragen was es wohl sei offenbar ist es
in jeder tätigkeit um kunst ein anderes
ein anderes ist es dem magazin und der
strategie und sofort welches ist nun das
gut in jedem einzelfall wohl das um das
sind willen alles übrige geschieht dies
ist der medizin gesundheit in der
strategie der sieg der baukunst das haus
anderswo wieder anderes da jedem handeln
und entschluss ist es das ziel denn
dieses ist es weswegen dessen man steht
das übrige tut wenn es also ein ziel
alles handelns überhaupt gibt so wäre
dies das zu verwirklichen die gute und
wenn es mehrere solcher ziele gibt dann
sind es dieses so ist die untersuchung
auf einen anderen wege im selben punkte
gelangt ist dahin mal also wir sehen
jetzt bei aristoteles wird das gute in
vier konkreteren bezügen gedacht wir
müssen noch mal schauen wie das
theoretische leben fast weil da ja
eigentlich das absolute gute gehandelt
wird wichtig ist hier
es geht um das leben also das gute wird
bei platten nur bei aristoteles nur im
theologischen kontext also im ziel und
zweck haften kontext eines lebens oder
eine lebensform thematisch das heißt wir
können hier hin schreiben wirklich
biologie oder lebensvollzug und er sagt
selbst dass denken das betrachten ist
eine form von leben von zig haffter
existenz weisen und das wollen wir noch
mal in der nächsten sitzung kurz
betrachten und dann gehen wir über zu
proteinen der wiederum an platon
anknüpft also hinter aristoteles
zurückgeht und die idee des guten und
des einen auf eine ganz besondere weise
zusammen denkt und dieser platonischen
wendung von der idee des guten als
jenseits des 1
die eine besondere bedeutung noch zu
geben versucht dann bis zur nächsten
sitzung